Ray J Bobby Brackins
the one-two punch
knockout
[Applause]
new record we promote
Ray J Bobby you guys we were just
talking one four three
is a bit of a classic and it's I can't
even believe it's been 12 years 13 years
since that song came out yeah what is uh
I mean because you had come in under
knockout or did that record come out
under knockout nah that was Bobby record
that was your record I just I really
just he told me it was going to be a big
record and I said listen I believe in
you I believe in the record and I'm like
dang he was he was a hundred percent
right the [__] is lit and um and then
they just went from there so what is the
inspiration to come back together all
these years later I mean we had we've
had the the other song Hit It First Hit
It First yes which made a lot of noise
yes and then you know I mean right there
versus like a year and a half like a
year ago and then it was like why
haven't we been making no music you feel
me so we're about to do a whole EP we
about to go studio right after this yeah
I think Bobby is really talented he's a
creative director right you know great
right writer producer and um and you
know sometimes when you're working with
people that's real creative and in their
own space and then they own bubble like
they dreams is already like it's already
stamped they already true
um and it's a lot of it's only a few
other people out there I work with that
when they say something gonna happen and
they manifest it you can feel the
manifestation in it then it actually
evolves with the hard work so I was just
like listen we need to go back in do it
again we ain't never lost
um and let's just do a whole EP a body
of work and I just trust you like he he
running the whole play you know I'm
saying wherever I could support
financially or just like me being there
following his lead through this campaign
I'm all the way in and I'm excited uh
for people who don't know Bobby
obviously we know 143 but your pen game
is pretty ridiculous you've you're uh
you helped write loyal right yeah uh
what are some of the other records that
um services to uh
let's see I'm the one with the DJ Khaled
Justin Bieber worked on that one did
worked on ego death for Kanye and Ty
Dolla great [__] record shout out to
Ty Dolla Sign
um the other one for Chris was came to
do it was off that I remember that
record that was a great record you know
what I came to do exactly and then uh
I'm sorry it's all good man it's a bunch
of songs you know I've been I've been a
part of been done touched you feel me
writers written by Bobby Brackins on
Spotify you could look it up you feel me
but definitely of uh you know try to do
my thing
how do you feel like uh because I feel
like since you came out Bay Area has
evolved so much in terms of the music
scene
um I feel like you know when you came
out kind of like the r b like hip hop
100 BPM I'm thinking your record I'm
thinking John Hart I'm thinking like all
that kind of [__] was like love rants
there was like this wave coming out of
California as a whole the bay is kind of
like it's kind of an interesting place
because it's kind of like if you think
about like the biggest artist out of the
Bay right now so independent guy Larry
June you know what I'm saying like
hilarious homie too Larry doing and
stuff man I'm proud of Larry man so I
was like Larry you ain't even had like a
big radio record exactly it's crazy
right you just got fans I'm passion all
over the world so the times just changed
you know like I feel like me and Ray our
artists who've had success
um like doing like radio runs and you
know getting that kind of marketing but
you know there's just two ways to do it
or you know you know like Larry you
don't need the radio you just get you
know that little core base that this
rocks for sure but you know this is
different way Different Strokes for
different folks I was gonna ask you how
do you feel about like the current state
of the Bay Area seeing and who you who
you're a fan of I mean I mean geez he's
still one of my brothers I love G and
then um Larry's of course doing his
thing okay Lonnie of course is doing her
thing and then um let's see this is no
kidding and Corey he just signed with
like the OVO click okay he got this song
called 4am and Oakland he doing his
stuff but it's um pillows my brother you
know pillow
my bro shout out to pillow you know but
you know it's a lot of creative stuff
always coming out of the bay and um now
it's just you know time to focus on what
me and right work you know the new
record new EP on the way